[Music]
faster but less severe
omicron leads to milder disease courses
according to recent studies in south
africa
the country's been at the front line in
the battle against the coronavirus and
its variants
using advanced technology to sequence
the genomes of thousands of samples
south africa's network of virus
researchers identified both beta and
omicron
the nation complains it was punished
instead of applauded for discovering the
variant
it was cut off by so many countries that
introduced travel bans and other
restrictions as cases rose
welcome i'm ben fazoulen the rise of the
omicron variant has led to a surge of
covert cases across south africa it's
also led to the cancellation of one of
the country's biggest parties
the bolito rage music festival after
dozens of revellers tested positive
it's south africa's biggest school
leavers party the balito rage festival
five days of dancing and fun but last
year the coronavirus was also among the
revelers and hundreds of people became
infected with kovit 19. organizers went
ahead with the event again this year
raising fears among the local community
in nearby balito if you look at what
happened the last time of course i'm
worried yes because it affects us
locally quite quite badly and all those
you know all the
youngsters are going back home
it did cause a major issue i think last
time we saw a major peak after that and
i thought i think that was a big
contributor i don't think it's a good
thing because we have that para pandemic
happening here so it can cause more
virus around because there will there
will be too many students around there
and the coffee to spread
fast so i don't think it's a good thing
to happen but now the festival has been
abandoned as the threat of omicron looms
in the past two months life almost got
back to normal here in south africa with
new infection rates being extremely low
down to less than 100 new infections a
day in the beginning of november but now
we are seeing an increase of infections
and experts are saying that this is the
beginning of a fourth wave
scientists are warning against mass
gatherings because early data suggests
the new omicron variant is more
transmissible than delta
these are clearly a significant risk for
for being super spreader events we we
know that we've seen that play out
before
it seems clear that the vaccine
protection against infection
is is going to take a a significant hit
with this variant that
they're
it looks it looks
quite clear that that the protection
will be lower against infection
the organizers of balito rage have
already suffered from heavy financial
losses during the pandemic and the
cancellation of the festival is another
major blow
i hate it you know it affects my
business it affects my industry it
affects what we do for a living what
we're passionate about we're in the
business of happiness we're not in the
business of being shut down all the time
and told we can't do something
borderline criminalized for just trying
to earn a living and look after our
family and friends
more than 1 000 visitors from around the
country are now stranded
i'm very sad about it because this is
kind of the event that everyone plans to
come to the whole year
after our exams after our finals and
it's the biggest so we're kind of
heartbroken that we couldn't come to
this place i also think that with all
the protocols in place i don't think it
needed to be cancelled there was none of
we were all tested for covert 19 all
those who were positive were same time
in isolation vans i think without a
refund i think it was a little bit
unfair on all the students who came down
who now have to find other activities to
do or go home the promoter was hoping
strict safety measures would prevent the
spread of the virus but despite
mandatory vaccination and rapid tests
for all attendees they say the latest
health data forced them to call off the
event after just one day
from cape town what does the latest
clinical data from south africa show in
terms of how virulent this new strain
really is
well i have actually good news um so far
at least we are seeing um a picture of
much reduced severity compared to the
previous variants of the virus
one has to however keep in mind that it
is still early days so so there may be
worse to come
in in two ways um firstly because uh the
natural time course of infection you
know it takes a little while for people
to become more severely ill and we are
still in our early days and as numbers
are surging you know there are more and
more people with recent infection and
then secondly um as we've heard just now
um so far it's it's you know it's been
predominantly younger adults that that
were affected and there may be
behavioral factors together with
a likely
increased transmissibility of the virus
um but that also means that those at
highest risk of severe infection and and
you know that they need oxygen and and
need to be uh
transferred to intensive care units and
those groups have probably not yet uh
become uh infected to a larger degree so
you know i want to be quite careful but
so far uh what we are not seeing is the
feared scenario of uh rapidly increasing
numbers of seriously ill patients being
admitted to hospital and that is to some
degree encouraging so a milder uh
variant we're talking about here but
also less virulent
yeah that that you know that that would
be the the conclusion that it is you
know for some reason causes less severe
disease but but as i said there are many
factors that play into this for example
the profile of the population that has
become infected and the time course so
you know it remains to be seen whether
that holds up but so far at least we
don't have alarming signals um on the
other hand uh one also needs to realize
that um this virus seems very well able
to infect people with pre-existing
immunity
so in south africa about a third of the
adult population have been immunized so
much lower rate than in many
industrialized countries
um
and and but they will have you know some
degree of protection against um severe
disease even though um the chance of
becoming infected despite vaccination
are apparently high and the same is true
for people and that is the majority of
the south african population who have
previously been infected with covet 19.
so again it doesn't mean they are
reliably immune for long term but
it does give of course some degree of of
partial immunity um again which this new
variant the omicron variant can
undermine it it can infect people who
have recovered previously
but they are likely to also experience a
must a much less severe course of
infection so again that is something we
need to to keep in mind we may be seeing
a clinical picture which is determined
by the large degree of uh pre-existing
partial immunity um so you know again i
would say it is it is early days but at
least we are not seeing alarming signals
but what we are seeing very clearly and
finding confirmed because we we thought
it it would be the case looking at the
genetic profile of omicron
is the virus's ability to infect people
with partial immunity so that it
definitely can do this is now being
confirmed by actual population data what
about the reaction to this variant i
mean
we haven't seen the world act in unison
and act so quickly uh with all these
travel bans um during this crisis until
omicron came along uh did
wha what was that called for shutting
down these parties that we heard about
and and cutting off the country from the
rest of the world
well this is twofold i mean firstly i i
i'm absolutely on the side of of my
fellow south africans who are um you
know appalled at the at the swift uh you
know harsh reaction by by many countries
basically cutting off of travel uh from
south africa which is very harmful
seeing that south africa is now heading
into the what should be the main tourism
season so it's a it's a very important
uh uh activity for for the economy which
is now being you know all but ruined for
a second year second consecutive year um
so i think this is not not warranted and
i very much hope that um these rules and
regulations will be revisited uh you
know at short intervals and will be
corrected
once they turn out not to be necessary
as regards uh events like like the uh
this this festival that that was
mentioned
um i absolutely share the the sentiment
that this is the wrong time to be
holding these um we are dealing with a
variant that's surging and leading to
surging case numbers um we are not
entirely sure just how virulent or not
this new virus is but we do know that
our vaccination rates are far too low to
to provide a a good uh general
protection to most uh people who are at
high risk so i i would actually even uh
hope that the government is now
thinking about
introducing
certain additional measures because at
the moment they have not changed the
general precautions they remain as they
were during those
weeks when we had very low numbers we
did enjoy a very nice early summer where
things were very relaxed and you know
how easy it is for people to to to dump
their masks something mine is lying here
on the desk uh but you know it's it's
it's it you know old habits come back
and that is perfectly fine but now is
not the time to be slack about it now we
need to to tighten it up again and so i
i fully support this and i think
gatherings should be avoided uh should
be held under in open air and and with
the very limited numbers
otherwise we are risking a
sustained rapid spread of this virus
and that is in no one's interest
are we also risking transparency because
south africa was so transparent about
this but it was punished not applauded
um
is that something that
that is at risk
you know it's the second time in a row i
mean it is almost a year ago that we
also discovered the better variant at
the same time that the uk found the
alpha variant um and at the time already
um travel bans hit the south african
economy and south africans very hard and
it took many months for them to be
lifted again
and now that
they have been lifted for for only a
relatively short while now they have
been brought back so yeah there is a
feeling of frustration and and people
are actually hostile towards um
my colleagues and me who are
running this surveillance network for
for the genomic surveillance of of the
virus in the country um we are basically
being accused of of having brought this
this uh a miserable condition upon the
country by you know doing our work and
by publishing it but of course
all countries are actually obliged to do
this so it's not a question of choice it
should just
be met with a more rational response and
i i think there is a serious risk that
countries may be discouraged from doing
the same and we know that many countries
are not yet able to do such um genomic
surveillance which is demanding
expensive and you know it's not not an
easy feat
but as we are seeing now again it is
important and you know any uh you know
time advantage in being warned allows
others as is happening now to check in
how far this new variant has arrived
already and is spreading locally so you
know we it should be in everybody's
interest that such work continues and
and you know
is being funded but
you know i think the the
global community is is risking the the
good will by you know by by being seen
to punish those who blow the whistle
neurologist wolfgang kaiser great to
have you on the show today
thank you
a viewer question now on anti-virals and
outside sky derek williams
i've heard of malnu piravir what other
antiviral therapies against sars kovi 2
are in development
antivirals are a class of drug that need
to be given soon after you begin to show
symptoms of a disease that's because
they work
by interfering with viral replication
which reduces
the amount of active virus in your body
and and gives your immune system some
time to catch up
uh rem deservier is the best known
antiviral in covid19 therapy
it's been used to treat patients since
the early days of the pandemic but
but experts have also disagreed about
how effective it really is and
administration is limited to to medical
settings because it has to be given
intravenously
uh malnupiravir
the new antiviral that you mentioned
that's made by merck
it can be taken in pill form at home um
it has just been narrowly approved for
high risk patients in the u.s by
an fda advisory panel until recently
it was viewed as really quite promising
but new results show it's not as
effective as authorities had originally
hoped but the baton of hope has been
taken up by an antiviral called paxlovid
which is made by pfizer
last month it said that its new drug was
nearly 90 effective at reducing the risk
of hospitalization
and death from covet 19. which if true
is a fantastic result though
pfizer hasn't published that trial data
yet so
investigators might be less positive
the company has also agreed to allow
generic drug manufacturers to make pax
love it for
low and middle income countries which
could increase supplies really quickly
if it's approved
there are plenty of other antivirals
that are being studied and and some have
received emergency approval in a few
countries including some
that were repurposed after being
developed to fight other diseases but
results with them so far at least
don't indicate that they'll be game
changers
[Music]
stay safe and see you again soon
[Music]
you